bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
alors la france qui est des landes en
échange de bons procédés puisque au mois
d'avril s'étaient lang qui avait aidé la
france oui ce sont des bons procédés
mais c'est surtout des échanges
symbolique parce que 130 respirateur à
l'échelon de la population indienne
c'est quand même assez symbolique pas
autre chose pas dire autre chose mais
c'est très bien j'ai regardé l'émission
avant et les échanges entre les pays
c'est un vrai problème la circulation
mais la circulation intérieure à chaque
pays est aussi un problème est justement
est ce que vous trouvez qu'il y ait
assez de solidarité mondiale face aux
combines 19 ça c'est très difficile à
dire
ce qui est frappant c'est là la
communauté scientifique qui est tout est
en ligne très vite c'est pas toujours
pas toujours très sérieux mais quand
même
les données sens incroyablement
disponibles on peut réfléchir les
papiers sort très vite ça c'est assez
remarquable c'est une sas est une grande
solidarité scientifique et la solidarité
sanitaires c'est pas très sûre on n'a
pas vraiment utiliser l'expérience des
pays d'asie qui se sont très bien sortis
du virus que ce soit la chine taïwan la
corée du sud hong kong et on peut même
aller jusqu'à l'australie la nouvelle
zélande cp lys se sont vraiment très
bien débrouillé et en europe on a fait
assez mal et dans les amériques
c'est peut-être encore pire donc ça et
on n'a pas vraiment su profiter de la
solidarité et d'apprendre de ce que les
gens avaient observé dans ces différents
pays
l'actualité en forme en fait faux bond
épidémique 1 en europe quelle lecture en
faites vous est-ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter
je dirais pas que c'est un rebond après
le confinement on est arrivé à enrayer
la face catastrophique
il en est un bien à redescendre de ce
sommet
c'est insensé où le nombre de cas
doublait tous les trash ou nombre de
morts 2 b tous les trois jours
mais le virus a toujours continué à
circuler dans le pays et continue à
circuler et ensuite les différents pays
qui sont tous arrivés à peu près à
contenir en europe à sortir de la phase
très aigu gère un peu différemment la
suite des événements et certains pays
reconfirme localement et est massivement
n'est par exemple en allemagne où il ya
neuf mille morts pour une population
beaucoup plus importante que la
population française contre trente mille
morts en france il re confine à bon
escient si je puis dire pour tester
massivement en france on laisse le virus
continue à circuler
on se concentre sur les foyers qu'on est
content room et des foyers qu'on trouve
c'est quand on trouve trois cas qu'on
peut relier entre eux et qu'ils sont at
il diagnostiqué dans un délai de sept
jours
c'est seulement la partie émergée d'un
iceberg les cas qu'on trouve c'est
vraiment une fraction à ces minuscules
des cas qu'on observe en vrai de qu'on
n'observe pas justement si on parle des
30000 morts et qu'on pense que la
mortalité de 0 8% ça va être ça plus tôt
il ya eu plus de 3 millions de cas en
france et on n'en connaît que 180 milles
donc les cas reconnus sont que la partie
émergée d'un iceberg donc le virus
continue à circuler et pour le trouver
il faut tester massivement la population
choses qu'on ne fait pas on fait
énormément de test mais sans aucune
stratégie identifier n'importe qui peut
aller se faire tester les résultats
arrivent beaucoup trop tardivement pour
être efficaces du point de vue de la
protection parce qu'il faut trouver le
virus quand les gens sont contagieux si
vous faites testé aujourd'hui quand vous
dis dans dix jours
vous étiez positif vous n'êtes plus
positif donc ça sert à rien de la de
savoir en fait qu'on a un vrai problème
de gestion de l'épidémie dans ce pays
merci à beaucoup d'avoir été en direct
avec mon quatrième je rappelle que vous
êtes
juste à l'institut gustavo gustave
roussy à villejuif dans le val-de-marne
merci